THEY ALLOWED US TO FILM
WITH OUR CAMERAS,
BUT WHAT THEY DON'T KNOW
IS THAT EVERY WORD I SAY
IN THE INTERVIEW
WILL BE DECIDED
BY A SEVEN-YEAR-OLD BOY.
THIS IS AMIR,
AND HE LOVES THE COLOR ORANGE.
- MY FAVORITE COLOR IS ORANGE
BECAUSE--
BECAUSE ORANGE--
IT COULD--
- SO BY ONLY SAYING
WHAT AMIR TELLS ME TO SAY
THROUGH THIS HIDDEN EARPIECE,
OSTENSIBLY GIVING ME
THE BRAIN OF A SEVEN-YEAR-OLD,
CAN I LAND THIS HIGH-POWERED JOB
BASED ON CONFIDENCE ALONE?
WELL, YOU'RE ABOUT TO FIND OUT.
- WHAT WE ACTUALLY DO HERE
IS WE FILE A LOT OF DOCUMENTS
IN THE COURT, MOTIONS.
WHY WOULD YOU WANNA WORK
IN A LAW FIRM?
- BECAUSE IT SAYS
"NO BAD GUYS."
THERE'S NO BAD GUYS.
- AND SO NO BAD GUYS
COULD COME IN THAT TOWN.
- SO NO BAD GUYS
UM...
- WHAT'S THE NEXT QUESTION?
- OKAY.
WHAT KIND OF EXPERIENCE
DO YOU HAVE IN THIS FIELD?
- WHAT THAT MEANS.
- LEGAL EXPERIENCE.
- COULD WE JUST NOT DO
THIS QUESTION?
- CAN WE NOT DO
THAT QUESTION?
- OKAY.
DO YOU KNOW HOW TO FILE
DOCUMENTS IN THE COURTS?
- DO YOU LIKE SKATEBOARDING?
- NO, I DON'T
LIKE SKATEBOARDING,
BUT I ASKED YOU A QUESTION.
- CAN WE MOVE ON?
- OKAY.
- IT SEEMED LIKE I WAS NAILING
THE INTERVIEW.
AND AT THE END,
I ASKED MS. CASTANITA
FOR AN EVALUATION.
ALL RIGHT, SO I KNOW
THAT WAS A MOCK INTERVIEW.
BUT IF THAT WAS A REAL JOB,
WOULD YOU HAVE HIRED ME
BASED ON WHAT YOU SAW?
- NO.
- BUT MAYBE?
- BUT MAYBE THOUGH, RIGHT?